good morning john
this is my office i've been making
videos in here for like eight years i
feel like i've never showed anyone
around maybe i should do that today the
thing about me is that i'm sort of
hyperactively focused on whatever
current problem i am trying to solve and
so i don't take a lot of time to like
look back at what i did in the past how
i get around that is by putting things
on my walls that i will see
that remind me of things that that have
happened that i have liked for example
this is a piece of art by emily grassley
that she made for me when she left
missoula this is the tour poster for the
hank green and the perfect strangers
this is the map of the world that
titan's great took place in sorry you
can't see it very well this is my joko
cruise poster signed by a bunch of joko
cruise people this is a bowling pin from
the time that i bowled a 199 in 2013. if
you watched every vlogbrothers video you
recognize this and what it is but if you
haven't
tell me what you think it is here we
have a stack of business cards i'm never
gonna look at and this is my tote full
of conference badges that's uh vidcon
london right there this is the x-wing
that catherine and i made during the
video that at the very end of a very
long video we announced that we were
having a baby where's the baby i'm a
small infestation of these little guys
right now this was from the merch table
of our tour where we were selling
gilbart pins for eight dollars if you
understood what that meant thank you
thank you for your support i used to
think i might do a gaming channel which
is why this corner looks like this
but it looks cool so i've left it
obviously things have not gone great for
this guy the head is ah there he is
that's curiosity up there next to the
air conditioner this is a piece of art
from vihart gotta have some star trek
the next generation and then maybe
giants or i don't feel comfortable now i
don't have a gaming channel anymore so i
have instead a microscopy station which
has brought me a tremendous amount of
joy i really can't keep the heads on my
bobble head that is a zay frank ducky
and if you want to go very very far back
into the history of vlogbrothers this is
the misprinted business card cube that's
some 2007 stuff right there here are a
lot of pins that i have collected over
the years this is a spur if you want to
put on your boot to like jingle around
when you walk but actually i got
for doing an event at university of
texas at austin what is inside the chest
though
oh
we can't talk about that down here is
the lizzie bennet diaries dvd set so you
can watch it on dvd which i can't do
because i don't have a dvd player this
month is actually the 10 year
anniversary of the first episode of
lizzie bennet diary and actually ashley
clements who played lizzie bennet is
doing a watch through vlog this year so
if you want to join here i'm going to be
on a few episodes of it you can find
it's called look back diaries this down
here is my collection of various coins
mostly project for awesome but there's
also my bim bam one there's a lore one
also and here's one of my favorite
things that i have let me try and get it
out
these are a bunch of different kinds of
crash course coins so like different
looks different feels as we were
planning out the first crash course coin
of what what was what is possible what
we could do like obviously this doesn't
make sense but this is just a bunch of
different things that they could have
done for that coin um and we also
things that we could do for future coins
i love these very much i honestly think
it's because in my head these coins have
a lot of value like they are the thing
that keeps crash course going people who
buy these so having like exclusive
versions of them like really gets my
collector sense going even though no one
knew that they existed until now but
nobody can have them they're mine up
there that tie is a tie that mr rogers
wore not actually one that he wore but
he wore that that plaid which our dad
bought for me you probably got one too
john he's a good dad and then of course
we got the meat furby and up there's the
bean furby very good pizza john thank
you to this person and of course we
still have and we'll always have the map
of the realm of narnia behind me that's
the kurt's gazette calendar this is my
first ever badge to a vidcon so that's
what it looks like in here this is the
place where i spend
a lot of my time i hope that was
somewhat enjoyable for you i know it was
for me john i'll see you on tuesday